[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com Donald Trump announced
yesterday that one of the things he's
considering in order to help with the
cool virus is to in-state a payroll tax
cut to offset damage that the outbreak
would have on the American economy and
the stock market and the idea of course
would be that if you put in place a
payroll tax cut you may be able to
reduce the effective lost earnings so
imagine that you know hours are reduced
at a business because there's less
demand a lot fewer customers businesses
cut hours by 20% imagine that if you can
cut the payroll tax the 20% cut in hours
maybe would only equate to like a 5%
drop in net income because you're paying
a lower tax rate on the money you are
making this is sort of the general idea
and this is being sort of promoted as in
the midst of all this Trump wants tax
cuts yeah it is but this is not just a
tax cut for the rich like I think that
the idea here if it's done if it's
targeted correctly is to get people to
say you know what I can actually afford
to stay home or I won't be as negatively
impacted I'll still have spending money
the idea is not the craziest idea that
Trump has come up with it is a more
stimulative type of tax cut yeah I
suppose it's not the worst idea ever and
when we think back to Obama's stimulus
package a good portion of that was
actually tax cuts and that's something
that people often forget Republicans
especially so it's not the craziest
thing to put out there but it does seem
like every solution Trump has what this
stuff just has to do with cutting taxes
like yeah back before the midterms Trump
wanted some positive press for
Republicans he wanted to give them a
shot at having a good day during the
midterm elections and he that was one of
the things he put out there even though
they had just passed the what was a
2017-2018 tax cuts right they wanted to
push it for another tax cut sort of
implying that the first one was for the
rich and that this one was going to be
for the middle class
is gonna be an actual good one for the
middle class well what you're pointing
out it goes beyond just tax cuts it's
always the same tools for Trump right I
mean no matter what the situation is the
tools that he considers are tax cuts
building a wall I mean we've been seeing
that with the cool virus which is well
we really need a wall we used to need it
to protect ourselves from violent
immigrants now we need it to protect
ourselves from the virus so it's always
the same tools tariffs when it comes to
international are we putting tariffs on
people geopolitics and trade the guy
only has a limited number of tools at
his disposal because he just doesn't
really know very much and that's what
we're seeing reflected here very simply
yeah and yesterday at the press
conference before handing it over to
Mike Pence he said that we're also
talking to the hotel industry and some
places actually will do well in some
places probably won't do well I'm not
entirely sure if the hotel industry will
do well because of the coronavirus I
guess the idea is maybe people will want
to stay sort of like locked into
whatever I don't know but you know it
definitely goes to the point that Trump
owns hotels yeah we definitely looking
after himself I mean when he says that
he's talking to people who are in the
hotel industry I think he's just talking
to his his own head listen I think we
need stimulus for golf clubs there's
nothing healthier when there's a virus
than being outdoors very often when
you're on the golf course you are you
know even 50 feet away from the people
that you're playing with because you
guys are hitting your balls all over the
fairway or even off the fairway it seems
to me that the government should get
very involved in stimulating people
going to golf courses because that's a
place you want people airplanes your
tightly-packed golf course you're out in
the open very low risk of transmission
obviously I'm kidding but it's no
surprise to see Trump come up with
something that would at least
conceivably funnel more money directly
into his own pockets and then we I might
talk about this tomorrow but we'll
mention it so now so we had this
congressman Matt Gaetz he wore this huge
gas mask on the floor of the of the
house to kind of ridicule the virus
turns out he was hanging around with the
people at CPAC who were exposed and then
yesterday he rode on Air Force One with
Trump and now Matt Gaetz who made fun of
the entire thing is under self
quarantine and people are increasingly
saying has Trump actually been tested
for the virus and so far as far as we
know Donald Trump has not
don't actually think Trump has it it
seems that it is marginally more
difficult to transmit than some people
are making it out to be but still very
much transmittable I don't think that
right there's already ideas paths that
the white house is hiding that Trump has
the virus I don't believe that at least
for now
yeah I don't believe it either but it
definitely is a risk I mean you have
three people right now who are in their
70s running for president they're
holding these big rallies going all over
the country well probably not shaking
hands anymore because now they want to
do like that terrorist elbow fist bump
thing yes of course
but even though they're not shaking
hands now they probably were for the
past few weeks or so in of course you
may be carrying the virus before you
show symptoms so the chances that Trump
or Bernie or bi didn't have having the
corona virus those are still very very
small but it always is a possibility no
question about it and of course with
every person you come into contact with
you are significantly increasing the
probability that you're in contact with
people who have been in contact with
someone who has it tomorrow or I guess
maybe today later today the Alabama
House of Representatives is going to
debate a bill which would look at
lifting the ban on yoga during gym class
in state schools this has been proposed
by a Democratic legislature if it passes
with a two-thirds majority in the state
of Statehouse in Alabama it would then
move to debate in the Senate this goes
all the way back to 1993 back in 93 the
Alabama Board of Education blocked yoga
hypnosis and meditation from public
schools after conservative groups said
that they should do this then the ban
got more attention in 2018 when a list
of prohibited gym activities was
circulated and yoga was on the list
now I understand banning hypnosis in
schools particularly because hypnosis in
general is quite more questionable I
don't know why you need hypnosis in
schools that makes sense to me
meditation and yoga have been very
successfully used in gym classes in home
rooms in all sorts of different places
and it reminded me of Pat Robertson that
televangelist he has this list of stuff
that can be demonic and it includes feng
shui it includes
sweaters from secondhand stores it
includes
Ouija boards and all sorts of stuff and
yoga is one of the things that can be
demonically possessed according to Pat
Robertson that's what I immediately
thought of and when we researched it and
learned the band goes back to something
pushed by conservative groups zero
surprise in my mind yeah with the Pat
Robertson thing is he okay with normal
stretching but if you hold these
specific types of poses for too long
then it becomes demonic like at what
point does it become demonic those yoga
if you're stretching in a hot room
that's definitely demonic and if you
have a hipster yoga teacher directing
the stretches the stretch has become
yoga and become demonically possessed
okay so if the room is 85 degrees and up
demonic 84 degrees and below not to
Monica basically that sounds about right
to me and also they would if they bring
back yoga into these Alabama schools
they would have to have English names
for all of the poses because it would be
way too scary if we had these four names
for this stuff and you know of course
like yoga is it does have some strong
connections to the Hindu religion but
like it's definitely thought of as a
secular form of exercise nowadays right
I mean maybe when it first got brought
to the west people thought of it as tied
to Hinduism inherently but I don't think
there's that association anymore not
really I mean the way it's practiced you
know other than the names of things it's
become I mean in some places it almost
is pseudo religious I've seen some
interesting documentaries about people
for whom Yoga is almost a pseudo
religious thing but now in my mind it is
not a religious practice hey here's some
interesting news remember that guy Steve
Bullock who ran for the Democratic
presidential nomination a few months ago
he's the governor of Montana most of us
have completely forgotten about him I
think he was polling like 0.3 at his
peak maybe maybe a little bit more he
has made the decision to run for the
Senate in Montana trying to unseat
Republican Senator Steve Gaines and I
think this is a great idea it may not
work but Bullock is already governor he
has some I guess additional recognition
because he ran for president even though
the campaign didn't go particularly well
you know I talked about beto getting
back down to Texas and running against
who's that not Ted Cruz dr. Korner John
Cornyn
yes I was thinking Jeremy Corbyn but
it's John Cornyn now very similar name
that could be something better could
consider I think it's probably too late
now but I think this is a good idea and
when we look at our calculations Pat of
which seats could Democrats maybe take
in 2020 we weren't thinking of Montana
at all and I find this a very
interesting possibility
yeah and Montana still is a red state
but they currently have that Democratic
governor in Steve Bullock of course and
they also have a Democratic senator
right now in John tester who was
actually just reelected in 2018 so it's
not inconceivable that Bullock can win
the Senate race there and that Montana
will go blue and yeah that would be one
of the states that we pick up that would
you know maybe get us towards a majority
I think you also need to pick up maybe
three or four more states assuming you
lose Alabama which we probably will yeah
and we've been talking about this over
the past couple years actually it looks
like the states would be Maine with you
know defeating Susan Collins Arizona
defeating martha mcsalley
yep Colorado there's a good chance that
we defeat Cory Gardner because that
state has gotten more and more blue and
Tom Tillis is also vulnerable in North
Carolina I don't think you have to sweep
all of those but I think if you get like
maybe four out of five then you take
back the Senate and that also depends on
if you have the presidency or not the
argument I break in Montana is even
though it is a red state Bullock has
overseen low unemployment in Montana he
has seen a growing economy
he has expanded Medicaid he reversed the
state's campaign finance laws to just
make the reporting requirements stricter
by political committees by PACs so he's
done things that are relatively popular
and have have a moderately large appeal
he has a case to run on I don't know how
the average Republican voter in Montana
would react to this but it seems like as
good a shot as there is for someone who
wants to enter at this point yeah I mean
I'm certainly to the left in my politics
of Steve Bullock sure but you know if
you're trying to get a red state to turn
blue there's a case be made that you
don't want to go to too far left because
then the Republicans probably just going
to end up winning yeah I mean I guess
there's this idea that you can sort of
excite the base and bring out people who
normally don't vote in progressives and
young people out to the polls but
unfortunately in this election cycle
seen from the states that have voted so
far young people aren't turning out to
vote the progressive ace isn't really
turning out to vote that much so you
know maybe that game plan is and all
that accurate what's interesting about
this and when we talk about the down
ballot effect of who is the Democratic
nominee and of course it increasingly
seems like it's going to be Joe Biden
one of the things that is being
suggested and it may not be true but
it's being suggested is that Biden being
the nominee may be good for Democrats in
the house and in the Senate now it may
not be good for the progressive wing of
the Democratic Party right but the idea
is that even the Steve Bullock race he
may be boosted because he is sort of of
the same ilk as Joe Biden if there's
momentum behind someone like Biden and
just because Biden's in the nominee
doesn't mean there will be momentum but
he would be the nominee there's the idea
and it's an optimistic one but it may be
partially accurate that some other
center-left Democrats may be able to
defeat Republicans it wouldn't be a
progressive coup but I don't know
something to think about I guess we will
see
yeah that's an idea that I used to shrug
off but now I think we have to take it
more seriously just seeing how this race
is shaping out I think that could be the
more accurate assessment and yeah I mean
like man when we were thinking about the
possibility of a burning presidency
which seems so much more likely a month
ago or even two weeks ago I thought a
Bernie nomination was more likely I was
I've always been skeptical that either
Democratic whoever's the Democrat is
gonna be drum well even if he was the
nominee that would give him a shot at
least right I mean yeah maybe maybe not
even that maybe not a 50-50 shot but you
know if you're one of the two candidates
remaining you definitely have a
good-sized chance of being president yes
and I was thinking like back then you
know we're probably not going to take
back the Senate though so even if
Bernie's president we would have the
house but we wouldn't have the Senate
for another two years at least so like
what could we get done now that it seems
like Democrats actually have a roadmap
for taking back the Senate it kind of
disappoints me honestly that we're not
gonna have Bernie in there because we
would have been able to get so many
great things passed possibly even
medicare-for-all if it was done through
a budget reconciliation yeah I don't I
don't think so but I think we would have
gotten things done again I just see the
path for a medicare-for-all so uphill
and remember that the the Democrats that
could conceivably win Senate seats are
not even in favor of medic
for all so it would certainly be an
uphill battle yeah I mean it would
require sort of changing the narrative
it would require President Bernie
Sanders coming in with this big mandate
and you know having to sort of like whip
everyone into place in the Democratic
Party and you remember like back a few
years ago when it was more of just an
idea there were a lot of Democrats
signing up for Medicare for all and
they've only since then gone against it
so you know it was it was never like the
most likely scenario but there was
always a glimmer of hope for and
unfortunately it looks like after
tonight all hope of that may be gone no
doubt it was something to fight for at
minimum and and just used as a starting
negotiation point if if nothing else
well we will see how tonight goes make
sure to join my livestream on YouTube
Twitter and Facebook starting at 8 p.m.
we will have results and all sorts of
stuff for you audience participation
it's gonna be wild very very wild and I
will see you then or otherwise on
tomorrow's program the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]